Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Seine Pileipilik. Ich bin hier die Dienstabende Ersin und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Aber so erst möchte ich wissen, wie Sie heißen.
Ich heiße Tanja Kuberski. Ich bin eine Frau.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, Tanja schreibt sich T, A, N, J, A, Tanja.
Und der Nachname Kuberski, K, U, B, E, R, S, K, I. Kuberski.
Frau Kuberski, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 41.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
69 kg.
Okay, Frau Kuberski, was kann ich für Sie tun, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Also, ich habe seit 2 Tagen Bauchschmerzen, die an Stärke immer mehr zunehmen.
Wo sind diese Schmerzen?
Genau.
Also begonnen haben die Schmerzen mehr so am Bauchnabel, um den Bauchnabel herum.
Aber in der Zwischenzeit sind Sie mehr nach links gezogen, links in den Mittelbauch und in den Unterbauch.
Könnten Sie Ihre Bauchschmerzen genau beschreiben, wie es, ich meine damit, wie er hat dumm, sehr...
Ja, es ist ein Dauerschmerz.
Manchmal kommt so eine Verstärkung, manchmal, so alle 10 Minuten vielleicht.
Und er ist mehr so dumpf und bohrend.
Sind diese Schmerzen langsam oder haben Sie sich ausgetreten?
Die haben langsam angefangen, langsam.
Könnten Sie einen Auslöser erinneren?
Nein, kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Okay, gibt es etwas, die sich Schmerzen verschlimmert oder verhindert?
Also, ich habe gestern Abend versucht, eine Wärmflasche auf den Bauch zu legen.
Und das war nicht so gut. Das hat das Ganze eher verschlechtert.
Hätten Sie schon mal eine Beschwerden?
Nein, solche Beschwerden habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Erst einmal.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen bewerten auf einer Schmerzsegala?
Nur ist keine Schmerzen und 10 ist sehr starke Schmerzen. Wie bewerten Sie?
Ja, also im Anfang war das so 3 bis 4 zu Beginn.
Aber inzwischen ist es mehr 5 bis 6. Jetzt kann ich Sie nicht hören.
Ja, könnten Sie einen Schmerzmitteil dagegen angenommen?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht.
Und strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Nein.
Haben Sie Albrechen oder sind Ihnen übel oder haben Sie schon mal Albrechen?
Mir ist übel und das wird auch, glaube ich, etwas schlimmer. Aber bisher habe ich noch nicht erbrochen.
Okay. Was meinen Sie, sind Ihre Schmerzen von etwas abhängig?
Zum Beispiel mit dem Essen oder Bewegung, sind Ihre Schmerzen verschlechtert oder verhindert?
Also Bewegung mache ich nicht gerne. Ich glaube, das verschlimmert die Schmerzen, wenn ich mich groß bewege.
Ich verhalte mich lieber ruhig. Ich liege auf dem Sofa und auf dem Rücken am besten.
Haben Sie Fiebergemäßen vor 2 Stunden und da hatte ich 38,5.
Wo haben Sie gemessen?
Im Mund.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut, aber seit gestern oder seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, ist der Appetit nicht mehr so gut.
Da habe ich wenig gegessen.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut, aber die letzten beiden Nächte mit den Schmerzen habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen ist unauffällig. Stuhlgang war vor einem Tag, aber das war ziemlich wenig Stuhl.
Das hat mich gewundert.
Gehen Sie normalerweise jeden Tag auf die Toilette?
Ja.
Leiden Sie an Verstopfung?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Könnten Sie Ihren Stuhl genau beschreiben?
Oder haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches beim Verstopfung?
Ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Ich habe allerdings auch den letzten Stuhlgang nicht angeschaut.
Es war aber relativ wenig Stuhlgang.
Frau Kubarski, ist Ihre Monatblutung regelmäßig?
Ja, letzte Periode war vor drei Wochen.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen allerdings ein bisschen vermehrt Ausfluss bemerkt.
Aber das hatte ich schon mal vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Da war ich dann auch bei der Gynäkologin.
Ich gehe aber regelmäßig zur Gynäkologin zur Vorsorguntersuchung.
Das war zuletzt immer unauffällig.
Was meinen Sie mit Regenmäßig?
Alle Jahre oder alle sechs Monate?
Ich gehe einmal im Jahr zur Vorsorguntersuchung.
Frau Kubarski, leiden Sie sich an Irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe Insulinpflichtigen Zucker seit der Kindheit.
Ich habe jetzt leider alles vergessen in der Aufregung,
um Ihnen das alles zu zeigen, was ich spritze.
Nach welchem Schema?
Aber das bringt das hinterher.
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren einen Herzschrittmacher,
weil ich, das heißt, kranker Sinusknoten.
Mein Sinusknoten funktioniert nicht mehr richtig
und dann wurde mir ein Herzschrittmacher eingepflanzt.
Seitdem habe ich da auch gar keine Probleme mehr.
Als Jugendliche und als Kind hatte ich häufig Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Die Nieren arbeiten nicht mehr so richtig.
Manche sagen, das hängt eventuell auch mit dem Zucker zusammen,
aber eben auch mit diesen Nierenbeckenentzündungen.
Da gehe ich regelmäßig zweimal im Jahr zum Nephrologen.
Das sind meine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind mit zehn Jahren am Blindarm.
Vor neun Jahren hatte ich einen Kaiserschnittgeburt.
Ja.
Und vor einem Jahr wurde die am rechten Auge die Netzhaut gelasert.
Hatten Sie eine Sechstörung?
Ja.
Da hat die Augenärztin gesagt, das liegt am Zucker.
Hinten die Netzhaut hat Schäden.
Das wurde mit Laser behandelt.
Das ist auch besser geworden.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Insulin.
Insulin nehme ich eben ein, aber sonst nehme ich keine Tabletten ein.
Bis jetzt nicht.
Wie viele Mal machen Sie die Insulinspritze pro Tag?
Mehrfach.
Das mache ich.
Ich messe ja mehrfach auch meinen Blutzuckerspiegel.
Je nach Wert wird insulin gespritzt.
Aber das ganze Schema bringt mein Mann.
Das wird er Ihnen dann zeigen.
Sind Ihnen eine allergiebekannt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Frau Kuberski, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Genussmittelgewohnheiten etwas erfahren.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ich gratuliere Sie.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber ganz selten.
Vielleicht einmal im Monat.
Was trinken Sie?
Dann aber höchstens ein Glas Wein.
Frau Kuberski, als nächstes möchte ich über Ihre Familienkrankheiten etwas fragen.
Leiden Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist 74 Jahre alt.
Er hat hohe Blutdruck und hohe Cholesterinwerte.
Er hat vor 10 Jahren, 15 Jahren einen Herzschrittmacher bekommen.
Deswegen?
Wie ist das denn?
Ja, auch wegen Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Er ist einmal ohnmächtig geworden.
Da waren es auch spezielle Rhythmusstörungen.
Weshalb er dann den Schrittmacher bekam.
Meine Mutter ist auch 74 Jahre alt.
Bei der wurde vor 3 Jahren ein Gallengangskrebs festgestellt.
Das wurde operiert.
Und mir geht es recht gut.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Ja, eine Schwester ist 44 Jahre alt.
Sie hat ein entsündliches Gelenkräumer.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Rechtsanwältin.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie verheiratet sind.
Ja, wir haben eine Tochter.
Sie ist 9 Jahre alt.
Sie ist gesund.
Ich habe eine Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich mache mir Sorgen, was es sein kann.
Was habe ich noch nicht gehabt?
Frage Kubarski.
Jetzt kann ich nichts genaueres sagen.
Aber es könnte auch wegen Ihrer vorherigen Operationen
in Ihrem Bau haben.
Vielleicht sind Sie Ihre Schmerzen verursacht.
Deswegen muss ich Sie erst körperlich untersuchen.
Und Blut abnehmen, eine Abdominalultraschall durchführen.
Dann können wir wieder versprennen.
Kann ich jetzt noch etwas essen oder trinken?
Sobald wir alle Ergebnisse bekommen,
dürfen Sie am besten nichts essen oder trinken.
Also bis dahin.
Bleiben Sie bitte nüchtern.
Ja, gut.
Das können wir so machen.
Danke.
Ich möchte Sie umzuschreiben.
Die Patientensprache und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
haben vielleicht noch Ergänzungsfragen oder Unklarheiten.
Können Sie die Fragen bitte gerne stellen.
Ein Kollege noch eine Frage?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Treiben Sie manchmal oder regelmäßig Sport?
Ich jogge manchmal und mache auch manchmal Nordic Walking.
Zu Hause mache ich etwas Kräftigungsübungen auf dem Boden.
Zur Körperkräftigung.
Das mache ich.
Frau Baske, welche Verhütungsmethode Sie?
Mein Mann ist sterilisiert.
Okay, danke.
Ich hatte in letzter Zeit keinen Unfall.
Oder eine Verletzung oder einen Sturz.
Ölern Sie dich in letzter Zeit müde oder abgeschlagen?
Nein, nicht mehr als sonst.
Ich habe einen anstrengenden Beruf,
aber ich fühle mich jetzt nicht in der letzten Zeit nicht besonders schlecht.
Wie ernähren Sie sich Ballastoffarme oder Reiche?
Nein, ich versuche eine ausgewogene Ernährung zu machen,
auch wegen dem Zucker.
Da war ich auch mehrfach schon bei Diätberatungen,
bei dem Diabetologen.
Ich glaube, das geht ganz gut.
Ich versuche auch, viel Ballastoffe zu essen,
wenig Fleisch.
Das klappt ganz gut.
Danke schön.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie vor neun Jahren eine Kaiserschnitt hatten.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie einjährige Tochter haben.
Nein, neunjährige.
Ich habe noch ein Kind, eine Sobohrt.
Das war eine Kaiserschnitt.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie seit zwei Tagen Ihre Ausflüssen vermieden.
Deswegen haben Sie eine unangenehme Geruch bemerkt?
Ja, es ist etwas riecht, etwas unangenehm.
Ich habe immer etwas Ausfluss,
aber das ist jetzt seit einigen Tagen etwas verstärkt.
Aber es riecht etwas unangenehm
und ich hatte eigentlich vor, wenn das jetzt nicht besser wird,
dass ich jetzt in den nächsten Tagen zu meiner Gynäkologin gehe.
Aber jetzt haben Sie das echt mal erleden?
Ja, so kenne ich das nicht.
Das ist zum ersten Mal so.
Danke schön.
Ich würde gerne wissen, dass Ihre Schmerzen nur linke,
obelbauch, mittelbauch und unterbauch lokalisieren.
Mehr im mittelbauch und unterbauch, im oberbauch nicht so sehr.
Mehr mittelbauch und unterbauch lokalisieren.
Nicht überall und auch nicht im oberbauch, mehr links unten,
links, Mitte unten.
Auf dem Zifferblatt ungefähr bei vier Uhr.
Ausstrahlung hat gefragt?
Ja, hat gefragt, habe ich keine Ausstrahlung.
Oder Wanderung, keine Abwandung, nur Ausstrahlung.
Keine Ausstrahlung, keine Wanderung.
Wärme habe ich nicht gut vertragen.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Wärme, warme Fräche, die haben gemacht, aber...
War nicht gut.
Ja, war nicht gut.
Ja, was sagt die Kollegin, die weiß doch alles.
5 Minuten, könnten wir anfangen?
Ja.
Also, bitte schön.
So, Herr Nebelzig, heute haben wir eine neue Patientin,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte, haben Sie Zeit dafür?
Ja, habe ich.
Es handelt sich um Frau Tanja Kuberski.
Sie ist 41 Jahre alt, 1,74 m groß und 69 kg schwer.
Sie stellte sich vor wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehenden
seit zwei Tagen langsam aufgetretenen,
langsam aufgetretenen,
progredienter, wellenformiger, dumm fe und bohrende Bauchschmerzen.
Sie schmerzen sein, um so erst waren die Umbrikale.
Die Umbrikale schmerzen, dann die linke Unterbauchung gesogen
und die Schmerzintensität liege so erst bei 3 bis 4.
Und jetzt 5 bis 6 von 10 auf einer Schmerzsäkler.
Die Schmerzen sind erstmalig aufgetreten
und die warme Fläche sind die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Die Schmerzen begleitet von Nausea
und die Schmerzen sind bewegungsabhängig.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergab Fieber von 38,5.
Wo wurde das Fieber gemessen?
Im Mund habe die Patienten oral gemessen.
Die Schmerzen begleitet von Insomni
und die Stuhlgang vermindert.
Seit wann ist der Stuhlgang vermindert?
Seit 1 bis 2 Tagen.
Seit gestern hatte die Patientin Stuhlgang gehabt,
deutlich weniger als sonst.
Danke für die Info.
Sagen Sie ruhig, dass die Patientin sich nicht wegen Bauchschmerzen
vorstellt, sondern wegen Abdominalschmerzen.
Das wäre vielleicht vom fachlichen her noch gut.
Er begann unbelegal und der Punktum Maximum des Schmerzes
ist im linken Unterbauch.
Man nennt das auch Fossa Iliaka.
Der Schmerz ist gewandert.
Er war zentral unbelegal und hat sich jetzt lokalisiert
im linken Unterbauch.
Was hat die Patientin noch für akute Symptome?
Nausea hatte die Patientin ohne Erbrechen.
Denken Sie noch, ich sage jetzt ganz bewusst,
nicht den Fachausdruck, denken Sie an den Ausfluss.
Die Patientin hat über Ausfluss berichtet?
Ja, die genealogische Anamnese sei unauffällig,
bis eine vermehrte und riechende Ausfluss.
Sagen Sie Fluorgenitalis.
In den letzten Tagen bemerkte die Patientin
vermehrten Fluorgenitalis.
Fluor der Ausfluss.
Gut, also ich habe jetzt festgehalten,
die Patientin hat seit zwei Tagen Abdominalschmerzen.
Die dummen Rohren sind teilweise wellenförmig.
Der Schmerz begann unbelikal und hat sich in den letzten
Stunden mehr in den linken Mittel- und Unterbauch verlagert.
Die Schmerzintensität war Anfangs 3 bis 4
und ist inzwischen bei 5 bis 6.
Es besteht, was besteht denn noch?
Der letzte Stuhlgang war vor einem Tag,
aber wohl deutlich weniger Stuhl als sonst.
Anderes ist der Patientin nicht aufgefallen,
der hat den Stuhl wohl nicht inspiziert.
Der kann dann darüber nichts berichten.
Gut, gibt es Auffälligkeiten beim Wasserlassen?
Es gibt keine Auffälligkeit beim Wasserlassen.
Sagen Sie bei der Mixion?
Ja, bei der Mixion.
Aber sie leidet, sie habe in der Jugend und in der Kindheit
vielmein Pylonephritis gelitten.
Gelitten oder habe mehrfach Pylonephritiden gehabt.
Und die Nierenfunktion, können Sie noch sagen,
die Nierenfunktion in dem Zusammenhang?
Sie erwähnt, dass sie eine Nephropathie hat.
Deswegen geht sie zweimal pro Jahr zum Nephrologen.
Okay, gut.
Ja, gut. Was hat die Patientin für chronische Erkrankungen?
Sie leidet an Diabetes melektustyptype 1
seit der Kindheit.
Deswegen spritzt sie eher in Zulin.
Aber die Dosierung und der Therapie schäme nicht erinnerlich.
Sie habe keine dabei.
Das wird nachgereicht vom Ehemann, oder?
Der Ehemann reicht das nach.
Gut, was gibt es noch für chronische Erkrankungen?
Seit zehn Jahren hat sie Arhythmie.
Deswegen habe sie eine Schritt, Herzschrittmacher, bekommen.
Wahrscheinlich wegen, ich habe gesagt, krank Casinosknoten.
Kennen Sie den Begriff des Sickseinysyndrom?
Ich kann nicht erinnern.
Die Patientin ist keine Ärztin.
Sie ist Rechtsanwältin.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat einen Erschrückmacher bekommen.
Wir haben die chronischen Erkrankungen, die pyrlonefritiden.
Sie haben eine Nephropathie geführt.
Wir haben einen Insulinpflicht in Diabetes melektustyptype 1.
Seit der Kindheit.
Wir haben einen Zustand nach Schrittmacherimplantation.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Wahrscheinlich wegen Sexseinysyndrom.
Gut.
Bei Euphorationen?
Ja, weshalb die Voroperationen sein Folgende bekannt ist.
Vor zehn Jahren hat sie eine Ependectomy erfolgen.
Vor zehn Jahren ist es Sexuosasaria.
Vor einem Jahr eine Diabetes-Rethinopathie.
oder mit laser behandelte diabetesche Retinopathie.
Wir können ruhig sagen, vor einem Jahr erfolgte eine Laserbehandlung wegen diabetescher Retinopathie.
Gibt es auffälligte oder gibt es Besonderheiten in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Ja, Ihr Vater ist ...
Entschuldigung, sagen Sie ruhig, in der Familienanamnese ist folgendes Erwähnenswert.
Also bitte Familienanamnese.
Und dann sagen Sie ruhig, der Vater?
Ja, in Familienanamnese sind folgende bekannt.
Ihr Vater ist 74 Jahre alt und leidet an arterielle Hypotonie, hypercholesterolänemie.
Und er habe auch vor 10 bis 15 Jahren auch eine Herzschrittmache.
Und bei der Mutter, vor 3 Jahren, operiert behandelte Kolangeokarsinom.
Gut.
Und bei der Schwester, eine Arthritisromatische Arthritis.
Ja, bei der 44-jährigen Schwester, die 44-jährige Schwester leidet unter einer rheumatoiden Arthritis.
Gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die ananästischen Angaben deuten am Herstern auf eine Eleusinfolge Verwachsungen hin.
Und als differenzial Diagnostisch kommen in eine Vaginitis.
Aber Sie haben keine Beschwerden.
Was haben Sie keine Beschwerden? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Sag Sie, ich habe die Örolitiasis gedacht, aber Sie haben keine Beschwerden mit der Mission.
Deswegen möchte ich nicht beurteilen.
Wir haben als Erstes eine Beginn der Ildosyptomatik aufgrund von Arthesionen.
Was für Organe liegen denn im linken Unterbauch?
Normalerweise dachte ich, als eine Appendicitis.
Aber sie hat schon eine Appendectomie.
Aber im linken Unterbauch liegen dafür Organe.
Normalerweise bei einem normalen Citus.
Gecheless Organe?
Ja, eine gynäkologische Organe.
Und einmal auch Verdauungsorgane.
Es ist Kolon.
Es wurde schon genannt, es gibt gerne eine Sigma di verticulitis.
Frauen bekommen das häufiger als Männer.
Er ist der Krankungsalter.
Ich weiß nicht, um 40 schon beginnen.
Aber es kann durchaus eine Sigma di verticulitis sein.
Sie hat spärlichen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Sie hat den letzten Zeit vielleicht gar nicht so beobachtet.
Sie hat Fieber. Es gibt Entzündungszeichen.
Natürlich muss man auch ein etwas gynäkologisches System.
Eventuell eine Atenexitis im linken Unterbauch.
Vermehrter Flur in den letzten Tagen.
Ich würde sagen, dass es auf Sigma di verticulitis,
die Atenexitis,
und natürlich kommt bei jedem vor operierten Bauch,
kommen auch Athesionen in Betracht,
die zu einem akuten Abdomen führen können.
Das wären meine drei Favoriten,
die Diagnosen angeht.
Aber wir wollen hier nicht die richtige Diagnose stellen,
sondern die sollen möglichst die Diagnose eingrenzen.
Das ist so.
Hat jemand noch andere Diagnose-Möglichkeiten?
Nicht extrem seltene, aber die Häufigen.
Kommt noch etwas Häufiges in Betracht unter den Kollegen?
Wer hat der Erfahrung?
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Gefäßprozess...
Es kommt auch ein Kars-Prozess.
Genau.
Es kann auch ein Kolonkarzinom sein.
Sie hat aber keine Gewichtsabnahme vorher gehabt.
Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so vielleicht in Forderung.
Aber natürlich muss man das untersuchen und schauen.
Die Patientin muss natürlich nüchtern bleiben.
Deswegen stelle ich immer gerne die Fragen.
Darf ich noch etwas essen oder trinken?
Sagen Sie bei allen akuten Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, Sie bekommen jetzt von uns gleich eine Infusion.
Ich nehme Ihnen Blut ab und dann bekommen Sie einen Tropf.
Dann bekommen Sie ausreichend Flüssigkeit gegen Ihr Durstgefühl.
Möglich sollten die Leute dann nüchtern bleiben.
Gut, erst mal vielen Dank.
Das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Ich habe Sie sehr gut verstanden.
Sie haben die Fragen sehr klar gestellt.
Das denke ich gut reproduziert.
Denken Sie einfach darum, die Sachen, die sind Ihnen alle bekannt.
Bauchschmerzen möglichst nicht sagen,
sondern sagen Sie ruhig Abdominalschmerz.
Februar temperaturen.
Die anderen Dinge haben Sie aber gut benannt.
Pyolonephritis.
Das alles war alles gut.
Also, dann machen Sie Prüfung nächste Woche.
Am 4. Juni.
Das ist ja auch nicht mehr so lange.
Die Leute sind gut.
Dann würde ich sagen, ich melde mich bei Ihnen.
Wir gucken wegen Mittwoch.